[Musique]
les semaines se succèdent et les
théories du complot se multiplient
depuis le début de la pandémie de kobe
la chine se trouve bien souvent au
centre des obsessions des
conspirationnistes la dernière théorie
en vogue
la chine a créé de toutes pièces la
pandémie de kobe 19 pour doper son
économie et mines et celle de ses rivaux
d'entrée de jeu pour qu'une théorie
comme ça tienne la route
mais il faudrait que des données
indiquent clairement que l'économie
chinoise et tire profit de la crise mais
ce n'est pas ce qui se produit en ce
moment selon les experts que j'ai pu
consulter
quand l'épidémie s'est déclarée en chine
et que les premières quarantaine ont été
imposées le grand manufacturier la
planète est tombé à zéro tout s'est
arrêté
et comme le précisait ma collègue andré
de saint-arnaud journaliste spécialisé
en économie à issy rdi cette mise à
l'arrêt s'ajouter à des pronostics pas
mal moins prometteur avant même
l'arrivée du nouveau corner virus avant
la crise du coroner virus sont prévoyait
déjà peu près 5 ennemis % de hausse du
pib pour la chine en 2020 avec la crise
sans avoir tous les chiffres définitifs
en main les experts s'entendent pour
dire que ça ne dépassera pas 3%
ensuite le début de la pandémie a
coïncidé en chine avec le nouvel an
lunaire et la traditionnelle fermeture
des places boursières habituellement
fermé dix jours les places boursières en
chine ont prolongé cette année leur
fermeture de trois jours en raison de la
crise une fois les bourses rouverte
la baisse était colossal c'était le plus
important recul des indices chinois
depuis le crash de 2015 autres faust est
présenté par les tenants de cette
théorie d'une pandémie fabriqués par
pékin l'économie chinoise a recommencé à
rouler à plein régime
faux les mois de janvier février ont été
pénibles pour le secteur manufacturier
chinois un rouage majeure et essentielle
de l'économie chinoise et au moment
d'enregistrer cette capsule vidéo
on estime que le secteur manufacturier
en chine rôles entre 40 et 50% de sa
capacité
quant au virus à la source de la coved
19 non il ne peut pas avoir été créés en
laboratoire des recherches dont les
résultats ont été révisés
et publiés dans des revues scientifiques
indiquent clairement que le nouveau
coronavirus serait le fruit d'une
évolution naturelle en terminant pour
plus de détails sur ce dossier consulté
mon article sur le site web des
décrypteurs et n'oubliez pas notre
courriel
il est là pour vous allez salut
[Musique]